[Music] It would have been great
if I had been
prepared for it.For combat
purposes.I
don't know how much I've been tinkering with it one after another, but it's just a wild thing.No matter how many
Semios I have, I'm an
automaton that I don't have in my life.  You can't win. That
's a bluff. There are
very few people who want to become undead if they fall into the void. Especially if they want to obey or be manipulated by a magician, and
even more so if it's for their own sake. Still, there are
rare cases where a magician knows everything and still doesn't want to become undead.  There are
people who will sacrifice themselves
[Music]
Hunting
Knight
Everyone, don't mess with that guy with the beard.Other
than that, you
can do whatever you want.